[Music]
hey guys so there is this new trailer
slash tv spot of godzilla vs kong that
has just been released and
in it we can see many new scenes that
just changes the entire perspective of
the movie
we got information that they were gonna
throw something at us
in the last week of february and this
was it but then again we sincerely hope
they would hold out on releasing
anything else
till the movie is in the cinemas and we
don't really want a repeat of batman vs
superman whereby the entire plot of the
movie is known
before it is even out but we would still
show it to you all
if they do lol so let's get to the
breakdown
so there were two tv spots and the first
one started with a scene of
gia the little girl showing kong the
doll she made for him
they casually hinted that she was deaf
when they zoomed in
on her ear then gong went down on one
knee in front of her
this tv spot actually shows gong in a
very human way
as he is capable of empathizing with us
homo sapiens
in a very relatable manner then there
was the next scene of him actually
communicating in a unique
sign language and if you listen properly
you'd hear him say
hmm wills trying to tell that this is
his home
even the character maya simmons
expressed surprisingly
did the monkey just talk um excuse me
maya
that ain't no monkey that's ape or also
known as hairy cheeks
or also known as sim kong for your
information
yes so we get to the same scene of kong
being transported on top of a cargo ship
wait interesting fact about these kind
of ships they can actually carry a lot
of weight
the biggest cargo ships can carry a
hundred and ninety thousand tons of
extra weight
so yeah the laws of physics hold through
for the scene
we see a new scene of kong kind of
waking up as if from a sedated state
so we see godzilla in approaching hong
kong
as evident by the cable state bridge
that is present there
it seems that godzilla is already
agitated by something and that his
dorsal plates are glowing bright blue
full of nuclear energy ready for a
battle
then again we see the same ocean battle
scenes
short scenes of them but a new one with
gong actually punching godzilla back
again
again this is the second punch this is
after the [ __ ] slap
it seems like the big ape wasn't knocked
out and was fast to retaliate
and i suspect this scene would connect
with the one of kong
pushing godzilla back into the water so
this was followed with the scene of kong
holding the balance
ready to fight godzilla and then a short
scene of kong being exhausted and tied
after the battle
and this seems to be like in the early
morning
this is succeeded by a scene of the
madisons
and eileen andrews it seems like team
godzilla and team kong
aren't as hostile towards each other at
all except in the comments section
then we see one of these small hollow
earth anti-gravity vehicles
actually surfing the atomic breath of
the big g these vehicles are powered in
some way by a new energy source that can
create a force field shielding
the craft from the power of the atomic
breath otherwise it would just be
vaporized
and now comes the second tv spot and it
starts with nathan lynn telling eileen
andrews that he knows gia is only a
child but that
she is very important and that she is
the only person
gong would communicate with which means
that whatever journey they are
undertaking
whether it is transporting kong away
from the skull island
or towards the center of the earth g has
to be a part of the group
or else gong would not follow them and
that even though it is wrong
to employ a child like child labour it
is necessary for the future of the world
so yeah the ocean battle scene again
with kong beating his just widely
intimidating godzilla
or it could be in the battle of hong
kong
maybe and then we flash forward to one
of my favorite scenes
the part where kong alongside two heavs
or hollow earth anti-gravity vehicles
are on a journey to the place where the
big ape would enter
kind of like a cave with the hellhawks
and everything and get the titan storm
breaker
to battle the g-man we get a glimpse of
the hollow earth and as we have analyzed
earlier
it is true the mountain ranges are all
over the place they are upside down
on the sides and the place stretches for
hundreds of thousands of miles in either
direction
and we can see that the mountain ranges
the normal one
and the upside down ones are actually
converging onto a point and
and seemingly radiating out vast amounts
of energy
like the sun at the center of the earth
i wonder where they get that idea from
anyway stretch alongside the
protagonists are glowing blue rocks that
seem to look like streams of energy
and also like the part in the cave where
kong was standing on
so moving on next we see godzilla
slapping an aircraft out of the sky
i mean godzilla likes to slap that's
what this movie is all about
[ __ ] slaps and bit slaps and also it's
like me slapping mosquito during summer
but what i see what is strange about
this scene is that
many of you might have missed this is
the white glow that is emanating from
godzilla's belly
and it's just it doesn't really seem to
color code with the bluish nuclear
energy that he usually shows off
is godzilla pregnant hopefully not is he
being poisoned
that is actually just dumb for me to
even think about it um
so could this be a hologram that is
actually hiding the true face of the
mechanized titan
maybe or is it just bad cgi could be
then again the scene cuts to maya asking
if they are sure the monkey is going to
survive this
monkey why hairy cheeks please
thank you so she might not necessarily
mean that they
are not sure if gom would survive the
fight against godzilla it might be that
she is referring to the travel to the
hollow earth
and while saying it we see glimpses of
jia with gong
in the background with his big brown
eyes
lovely and den of kong running away from
the atomic breath
it looks like kong would really use the
surroundings to his advantage in the
battle
against the big g hiding and coming out
to punch him and hiding again and coming
out again
like coming out of the closet and using
his intellect as a weapon
that is his main advantage his intellect
then we get a glimpse of godzilla
roaring into the sky actually into the
camera but yeah the sky
as you can see here in this clip
godzilla's chest is blue in color
but why was the earlier one white
shining
differently only the movie will tell
then a snap scene of the team
are riding the heav into the hollow
earth and then we see madison russell
and her group of friends
apparently reaching an abandoned
facility and if you remember
the earlier trailer they were on a hunch
that
something is provoking godzilla and that
they were going to find out
so here is where they will land and we
just might
just see them confronting ren serizawa
or someone else
and uncovering the plots of
mechagodzilla in the movie scooby dooby
doo
then finally we get to the love scene of
come and godzilla roaring at each
other's face
that's just me and my girlfriend arguing
whether it's ramen or kfc for lunch
on a serious note however the details
for both the titans are highly enhanced
here and kudos to the ones during the
cgi
weather digital we love you this
deserves to push godzilla vs kong for at
least a nomination for best pitcher
award
if not winning it i see them winning it
winner winner chicken dinner
we can see godzilla is clearly on top of
kong in the scene
hey on top but the question is why
didn't the g-man
just finished the big ape off once and
for all after all
godzilla doesn't take chances and he
goes in for the kill right then and
there as we can see with ghidorah or the
murals
anyway what do you think we will
continue with that on another video
so here is this trailer tv spot we see
kong being the underdog and godzilla's
motive still hidden
and shrouded in a cloud of mystery which
is good as both
titans have their own storyline and also
that when they meet the story would
slowly unfold itself
it wouldn't just be any ufc match where
ding ding ding
fight and this will have a story that
would put the transformers to shame
well they didn't really have a good
story at all to start with
so with that we come to the end of the
video do hit that like button for
support
smash the subscribe button to be a part
of the mind cue family
and slap that bell icon if you're last
if your life depended on it
for regular updates of course on new
monster worst content right here on mind
cue
take care fam